So this is a lesson on
improving cache performance.
There are many methods for
improving cache performance, but
in general,
they can be grouped in three categories.
And these three categories
have to do with
the average memory access time or AMAT,
which is equal to hit time + miss
rate x miss penalty of a cache.
So pretty much if we always hit,
we get the hit time.
If we miss, we get the miss penalty and
how often we miss is the miss rate and
the average memory access time as seen
by the processor is equal to this.
So the methods for
improving cache performance can be
those that try to reduce the hit time,
those that try to reduce the miss rate
or trying to reduce the miss penalty.
All of these would reduce the average
memory access time, which improves
the overall performance of the processor
when it needs to access the cache.